in the last couple of videos we saw that
we can describe a curve by a position
vector valued function and in very
general terms it would be the x position
as a function of time times the unit
vector in the horizontal direction
plus the
y position is a function of time times
the unit vector in the vertical
direction and this will essentially
describe this though if you can imagine
a particle and let's say the parameter t
represents time it'll describe where the
particle is at any given time if we
wanted a particular curve we can say
well this is only applies for
let's say for some curve we're dealing
it's r of
t
and it's only applicable between
t being greater than a and less than b
and you know that would describe some
curve in two dimensions let me just draw
it here this is all a review of really
the last two videos
so this curve you know it might look
something like that where this is where
t is equal to a that's where t is equal
to b and when you know so r of a will be
this vector right here that ends at
that point and then as t or if you can
imagine the parameter being time it
doesn't have to be time that's a
convenient one to visualize these each
corresponding as t gets larger and
larger we're just going to different
we're specifying different points on the
path we saw that two videos ago and in
the last video
we
thought about well what does it mean to
take the derivative of a vector-valued
function and we came up with this idea
that and it wasn't an idea we actually
showed it to be true we came up with a
definition really that the derivative i
could call it r prime of t
and it's going to be a vector the
derivative of a vector valued function
is once again going to be a derivative
but it is equal to the way we defined it
x prime of t
times i plus y time prime of t
times j or another way to write that and
i'll just write all the different ways
just so you get familiar with dr
dt
is equal to dx
dt this is a just a standard derivative
it's x of t is a scalar function so this
is a standard derivative
times
i plus d y
dt times
j and if we wanted to think about the
differential one thing that we can think
about and you know whenever i do the
work the math with the differential it's
a little bit hand wavy i'm not being
very rigorous but if you imagine
multiplying both sides of this equation
by a very small dt
or this exact dt you would get
dr
is equal to i'll just leave it like this
dx
dt times dt i could make these cancel
out but i'll just write it like this
first times the unit vector i plus d y
dt
times the unit vec times dt
times the unit vector j or we could
rewrite this and i'm just rewriting it
in all of the different ways that one
can rewrite it you could also write this
as dr is equal to
x prime of t
x prime of t
dt
times the unit vector i sorry this was x
prime of
t
dt right this is x prime of t right
there times the unit vector i plus
y prime
of t that's just that right there times
dt times the unit vector j and just to i
guess complete the trifecta the other
way that we could write this is that dr
is equal to if we just allowed these to
cancel out then we get is equal to dx
times i
plus dy
times dy times j and that actually makes
a lot of intuitive sense that if i look
at any dr so let's say i look at the
change between
this vector and this vector
let's say the super small change right
there that is our
dr and it's made up of it's our dx our
change in x is that right there you
could imagine it's that right there
times but we're vectorizing it by
multiplying it by the unit vector in the
horizontal direction plus d y
d y times the unit vector in the
vertical direction so when you multiply
this distance times the unit vector
you're essentially getting this vector
you're essentially getting this vector
right here and when you multiply this
guy and actually our change in y here is
negative you're going to get this vector
right here
so when you add those together you get
your change in your actual position
vector so that was all a little bit of
background and this might be
somewhat useful in a future video from
now actually i'm going to leave it there
because what i really i just wanted to
introduce this notation and get you
familiar with it in the next video what
i'm going to do is give you a little bit
more intuition for what exactly what
exactly does this thing mean and how
does it change depending on different
parameterizations and i'll do it with
two different parameterizations for the
same curve